voyez regarder le disque je n'ai pas
plus grand ça existe pas plus grand
c'est les plus grands disques qui peut
exister
voici presque quarante ans que patrick
gélin collectionne un objet d'un autre
temps le phonographe comme un ancêtre de
nos chaînes hi-fi baladeurs et autres
lecteurs à l'époque enregistrée était de
l'ordre de la magie les premiers sons
ont été enregistrées sur une feuille des
temps et après la feuille des temps
ils ont donc fait le photographe à
cylindre à rouleaux qui étaient
enregistrés à l'époque voilà ce qui est
assez compliquée pour enregistrer parce
qu'il fallait chauffer le disque un
petit peu la vapeur et on pouvait avec
des appareils bien spécifiques
enregistré et écouter tous les objets
ici fonctionnent mécaniquement le
premier enregistrement a été effectuée
en 1881 charles cros a inventé l'objet
mais c'est l'ingénieur thomas edison qui
dépose le brevet les foyers donc les
plus aisés pouvait se faire à l'époque
un concert à domicile
le musée de luynes regroupe plus de 200
pièces est l'objet fétiche reste ce
phonographe portable non mp4
le voici le mp4 mécanise suisse c'est
suisse c'est à dire que tout se plie et
on peut mettre dans la poche
les fraises pathé ont créé à leur tour
un feu de graff unique celui ci semble
être à l'origine de la musique stéréo
toutes ces pièces sont une valeur rare
et les collectionneurs entre n'hésite
pas à se porter secours pour rendre
l'âme
un objet abîmé la tête et le pavillon et
le pavillon parce qu'on sait des
échanges de pièces détachées là je suis
capable de refaire la vie ce qui lui
manque comme à l'origine
donc je vais lui faire la vie c'est plus
on avancera dans sa collection
en france on dénombre 400
collectionneurs de phonographes le musée
lui fête cette année sept ans
d'existence
il continue de s'agrandir avec de
nouvelles pièces et tous les bénéfices
des visites sont pareilles reversés au
centre de loisirs de lulin